hey nice to meet you I like this did you
make that uh my uh stylist Brit I was
like can I get a velor suit with the
Transformer on it and she made it she's
the best check out shout out shout out
bread dude what does it mean to you to
be a voice Mirage in the Transformers
movie now like little kids want you to
autograph like how surreal is that dude
this is crazy this is crazy yes I've
been going to these movies forever I am
I'm freaked out I can't believe I'm
talking to you doing this thing this is
insane there's a giant that's you yeah
it's a 20 foot tall you bro I'm full out
of body here so excited and just
grateful and everyone a part of it's
been so nice that I'm just I'm excited
dude considering you geeked out on the
first Transformers film with Cheyenne
Megan did you hit Megan up to ask her
like yo I'm thinking about taking this
job what do I need to know about the
Transformers world oh I told call it
when I told Colton Mega they laughed
they were like that's that's sick they
were really stoked so yeah they were
really stung I mean it's big it's very
it's it's huge no pun intended with the
Transformer no yeah it's really exciting
man and Stephen did a great job and it's
just like it's it's Transformers yeah
you know you do so you can kind of put
your spin on Mirage like ad-libs riffs
like you know making sure that the
chemistry between him and and Anthony is
good yeah Steven was great he was just
like you know we'll do what we need
which is the script and then we'll do a
few takes like just you know be be you
do whatever and you know we would do a
bunch and mix them together and we had
fun man it was all you know Steven's
really really smart and these writers
were really smart and they they did a
great job did you find yourself in the
booth like karate like chopping and like
oh yeah I'm in it yeah I still didn't
believe I had like this is the now I
believe this is like a real thing
because like I was still freaking out
the whole time but I was going nuts in
there this is like a blast this is I I
did whatever Bradley Cooper did and rock
and raccoon that's exactly no you watch
those videos and they're having a
that's what it's like it's the best job
in the world I know love that oh maybe
the second best job in the world doggy
Daddy I saw this as I was coming over
here yeah what kind of puppy did we get
what's the name what's your do you have
the leash are you walking are you
picking up the poop yeah I gotta I'm
allergic to dogs uh so it's hard for me
to find a dog that I'm not allergic to
so I found a Cavapoo his name is Rodney
Dangerfield and uh I bought him a little
red tie and we're gonna teach him how to
go like this no yeah so he could tell
jokes didn't go like that yeah like no
respect I get it over hey yeah but he
actually really looks like Rodney
Dangerfield and it's gonna get a lot of
respect yeah and he's gonna get mad yeah
yeah before I let you go if if you could
have in your car the voice of a
celebrity like be the voice of your car
who would that celebrity be wow
um
don't say Colin jokes Will Arnett oh
that's a good one yeah Will Arnett has
like the best voice maybe of all time
yeah like it's just like I it's hidden
in plain sight that guy has a great
voice I think he's the Reese's species
guy yeah right and GMC yeah he's a
legend already the voice of cars bad
dude rocks he does rock that dude rock
is the after party for this on your uh
your boat yeah if it's not sunk I have
no idea what's going on with that thing
me and Colin were very stoned a year ago
and bought a ferry and we're figuring it
out it'd be a perfect place yeah for the
Transformers after party maybe not it
turns into a Transformer and gets the
out of here and floats yeah
foreign
[Music]